parce que je suis pressé
oh
nous attaquons voici un oiseau géronte
expliqué chez moi je vous regarde
derrière connaissez la fontaine d'ouche
et c'est connu les grands du qui rentre
par la fenêtre
ça sera sur le canapé regarde la télé
bah ouais c'est pas mal amusé
au maquis très précieux suivant l'adage
si le pardon d'avoir marqué rien la suva
du reproche aux gens d'avancer masqué tu
te pas regardé
si je me souviens d'un petit nom mais
parce que vous m'avez vu là enfin je
veux dire vous voyez vraiment tout mon
corps je vous trouve très très très
belle la première fois juste et vous
savez les épaules tellement base on
pouvait pas à se voir
la presse les épaules lève la tête tu me
marierai pas altier pour compliquer à
venir
puis rock bien avec ton petit coussinet
jerry apprécié ici encore ici